the hub network which they say is aimed
at kids but they have the old school
transformers and GI Joe on there so I
went off I'm
they're coming out with a new cartoon it
is called shezow
and let's watch a little of the
program
with this issue Ste
spam
he became a superhero
scored
uses said
dude no she said stresses uncomfortable
she's
know he's nazis she just first
ready to kick some she's
see yeah he's just a guy exactly
making the same sweatshirts
test as a good
she's you series
check your local listings
she's of work
Scout I miss you three alright sorry
case you were clear what just happened
there he has a 12-year-old boy
put honoring becomes a superhero girl I
actually a very similar experience hey
I alright is this part have the
hard-core left wing liberal progressive
agenda
to turn all our boys into girls because
you know that's come in
I think it's just a silly concept and I
think people are making such a huge deal
I've it for no reason
at all yeah although I would be offended
if I started to watch it and I
you know was thinking that maybe they're
making find them
its in a way then I would be if a given
a chance yeah
growth because when I just was watching
Matt the first thing I noticed was when
he first turn into a girl he was like
yeah
ok it's like that's like the worst thing
you can be right well that's the funny
thing it's like
if they wanted to if they were trying to
be pro trans or pro who
cross-dressing or or something like you
exactly and in this
it's like he is still playing on this
know it's not right kind of thing
which I think takes away from whatever
their controversy
would be yeah I you had
I just think I know their target
demographic is
22 11 and I really don't think you can
they're sitting there
right analyzing whether you're not like
they're like
home and like this transgender thing is
really like
you know stand-up act you know i think
im just saying this boy
it's entertaining if anything it smart
because you're appealing to the little
boy mark in the growing market
you know if one is a man that equals
money in that is fine
yeah is very accurate actually because
if you want to save the world
kinda have to be a woman yeah do you
have a special ring
thank you you but and yet you're not
wearing it's a new hiring
I A there you go and i know i
up by about $3 K I am
you know it's funny I remember when I
was a kid watching shearer
and watching JM and jim was made by the
same people with the same animators that
made GI Joe transformers
and sheer was made by the he-man people
but I remember thinking that I was doing
something wrong because I was watching
because it was
aimed at girls did you guys have that
kind of thing where you may be watched
like a GI Joe or something with that see
more boyish and
like to I wonder if girls have that or
or was it about Barbies and
its power rangers and there's nothing
else there so that's okay I i'm
I like mixed company okay
I'm by Axwell so I like every other guy
I like idling are all
I yeah I mean yeah I
understand I i feel like I got a comment
the other day about this guy saying is
it bad that I watch Pretty Little Liars
and I was like dude
own it that shows amazing yes all what
is that okay even
in adults that we think that somehow
watching something is good like
are straight people hanging onto their
identity by such as
in yet lot lately is that what is good
people don't watch
gay people were inundated with straight
images all the time are suddenly ok well
I better be straight with straight
people
if they see anything K like oh my god
yeah im Kino guys watching the notebook
was like I mean it was okay
like you Gare I just had to go there
yeah but yeah I think it goes back to
the whole challenging that kinda have
you you know male perception notes
have strengthened her sexuality but it's
like if you look back in history of
cartoons
it's not like this is the first time
that the homosexual or transgender any
type a plan that has been represented I
mean you have
Batman and Robin the Boy Wonder you know
you have the Fred Flintstone who
you know with Twinkle Toes for instance
hung out with Barney like all the time
yet
Bugs Bunny was across tracks roads money
yeah pathway
was a sailor who was dating above what I
love well could have been
as transverse shear you never know right
yeah
yeah well it so it seems to me that it
bears the one part is that i think is
that they're aiming at a kids
and people seem to think that we can we
can turn kids and that's the
the scary part here that that still
exist is the is the bigger
right I think that is a huge problem hey
I think people are reading too much into
it I think it's just a silly little
cartoon at all
I don't see the the problem with that at
all
anything it's just making people it's
making people
watch something that's about a guy and a
girl the same time
the app also kids just don't realize
this stuff right Lake
yeah when I was 10 watching Bugs Bunny
was
cross dressing like I never thought it
was sexually I just seemed funny to me
so it's a yeah the irony is that like
really
it with them making this more of an
issue it's like yeah
and bring it to life you know I don't
think it would have even noticed or
you have kids or anything yeah
ironically we're going to have this for
kids but are there any
trans characters on television in are
there
yes there might be one or two but like
any soda mainstream
mystique in the act yeah anyone
yeah and she has yeah Candis Cayne
used to be and I'm how God what show is
it
Camden O games be an Afghan detainees
issue she had ever on some
mainstream show wiped out there
something I can think is our eyes and
hair
I guess we got a way to go but the
people pub will lead us to gender
equality